in America between 2012 and 2019 the
suicide rate for girls aged 10 to 14
increased by 138 wow I think it's
something like 75 of girls posting or
users posting on Instagram are using
face tune the actual app has become like
the act of touching retouching your
selfies has become feminists so
pretending to look
in a way that you don't actually look is
now empowering yes yeah it's completely
changed well that's what all the
celebrities say I mean Khloe Kardashian
she literally facetuned her own newborn
baby when it was born and she calls it
life-changing plastic surgeons are
talking about this thing Snapchat
dysmorphia women used to come in with
pictures of celebrities that they wanted
to look like but now they come in with
pictures of themselves with a Snapchat
filter on so I think it's definitely
yeah the result of social media creating
unrealistic Beauty expectations that are
just kind of robotic cyborgian look that
you just can't replicate without filters
if you had a teenage child now would you
let them on social media no I wouldn't
either no I wouldn't all right well
before we wrap up then what do we do
about all this
foreign
[Music]
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our fantastic
guest today is a young writer who's
going to shed some light onto whatever's
going on with young people today friend
yeah welcome to true thank you for
having me it's so great to have you on I
am a massive fan of your writing I have
to say and you you don't write a huge
amount but all your articles I've read
and I thought this is someone who's
offering a new and different take on
some of the issues that I actually don't
get talked about plus Francis and I are
now both in our 40s so we need to see
young person to tell us what's going on
with young people but before we do all
that uh tell us a little bit about you
who are you how are you where you are
what's been your journey through life so
I graduated in 2020 I studied politics
at Uni and during that first lockdown I
just started to contribute to a couple
of online magazines so places like The
Spectator the new Statesman the
independent
and initially I was writing a lot about
politics social justice activism
feminism that kind of thing
but I felt that I was getting a little
bit caught up in what would get
engagement what was kind of trending at
the time uh so I wanted to take some
time to think about what do I actually
know and can actually give some value on
um and at the same time I was seeing
headlines everywhere for Gen Z's anxiety
epidemics uh rise in depression
self-harm suicide that kind of thing
um so I decided to make that my focus
and I'm currently working on a book
which is kind of a deep dive into girls
and their mental health and basically
how we got into this Mental Health
crisis and uh I mean one of the things
you talk about a lot is the young women
in particular yeah um what's going on
right because we don't know we keep
seeing headlines as you say there is
Mental Health crisis you know everyone's
got climate anxiety you know I joke
about it but you know what I mean like
what's going on with your generation
you've got to embrace the oldness now
mate but what is going on well I think
there is a mental health crisis I
generally do I think in the early 2010s
there was this spike in anxiety
depression other things like eating
disorders
um and I think at the time a lot of
people thought that's just nothing new
that's just kind of adolescence and
coming of age like you
everyone feels a bit anxious has body
image issues at that time
um but if you look into it the self-harm
and suicide rate was also going up at
the same time
massively so like in America between
2012 and 2019 the suicide rate for white
middle-aged men increased by three
percent but for girls aged 10 to 14 it
increased by 138 wow so it's not it's
beyond the normal experiences of
adolescence whatever's happening
um but I think what's happening now is
you know young people are having all of
those age-old feelings of anxiety and
Body Image issues the normal stuff
but it's colliding with other things in
Modern Life like social media
um consumers and all of these things
that are kind of ramping up
um and I think it's taking those normal
feelings and just exacerbating them to
the absolute extremes
138 yeah yeah that is absolutely
terrifying and it's awful yeah and you
how much of this can be blamed on social
media do you think how much of it can be
blamed on the consumerism how much can
be blamed on other factors as well well
social media is a bit hard because
there's not actually like definitive
evidence that it's social media
so some studies show barely any effect
of social media other studies show that
it's a huge impact
but one thing Jonathan height says which
I think is important is that when
they're looking at studies on social
media they often say screen time
which kind of lumps in texting and
scrolling through Instagram which has
different mental health impacts like
texting is not that bad for your mental
health so I think that's why it comes
out as barely anything it depends who
you're texting yeah that's true so yeah
so there's that so I think that um
it's difficult to definitively say but I
think if you look at the Timeline so
mental health started to decline in the
early 2010s especially for girls
the iPhone came out in 2007 Instagram
came out in 2010 you had editing apps
like facetune came out in 2013 Snapchat
was doing its AR filters in 2016. so all
around that time
these things were happening and girls
mental health especially was declining
so you can say it's things like the
climate crisis or the economy that's
affecting mental health but why would it
be girls and why would it be such a
sudden decline at that time and Frank
you used something I'm sounding so old
you the the face moderating app yeah
face tune face so explain to people yeah
like me who are very old what is this
app what does it do what is the purpose
of it and what are the effects on young
girls so face tune isn't editing out
selfie retouching they call it
um and you can basically do anything on
it you can tan your skin you can whiten
your teeth you can restructure your face
they've just introduced a new feature
where you can you kind of film yourself
doing something like walking around a
room you can freeze the frame edit your
waist so it's tiny and then that when
you play the video that will stay for
the whole video and it looks like that's
just your body so the technology is just
seamless now you can't tell that it's
been edited
uh it's been downloaded like 60 million
times I think and I think it's something
like 75 of girls posting or users
posting on Instagram or using face tune
um and the funny thing about facetune is
that
you know it used to be a bit of a secret
among teenagers like they would use it
and they wouldn't want other people to
know that they're using it whereas now
it's kind of been rebranded in this
whole feminism self-love thing so face
Tunes marketing is very much about uh
self-expression and girls self-love so
for example on International women's day
they posted something like selfie selfie
editing is a powerful Act of
self-expression and it was to celebrate
feminism so the actual app has become
like the act of touching retouching your
selfies has become feminists so
pretending to look
in a way that you don't actually look is
now empowering yes yeah it's completely
changed well
that's what all the celebrities say I
mean Khloe Kardashian she literally face
tuned her own newborn baby when it was
born and she calls it life-changing
you've got uh there's YouTubers online
who there's this guy James Charles he's
got 23 million followers and he does
this series where he gets like pre-teen
teen girls descending selfies and he
will edit them so he'll give them like a
nose job
Contour them put makeup on them and all
the while he's saying oh this is nothing
there's nothing wrong with fixing
insecurities you know this is
self-expression and all of the comments
are like this is so educational this is
empowering uh so it's really interesting
to me that it's been completely
rebranded it's really interesting
because before the only people who could
do that were the Vogues of the world
exactly and they would take a celebrity
and they would slim them down and trim
their waist and whatever else and put
them present an unrealistic
representation of what that person
looked like yeah but now it's
democratized here everyone can do it
yeah I think there was in the early
2000s like a backlash to the the photo
retouching in magazines and you know we
had growing mental health awareness
since then and I think corporations had
to come up with an answer and their
answer is to continue profiting off of
female insecurities but now wrap it up
in feminist packaging but then there's
also the flip side which when we see
morbidly obese people aren't and
particularly women in Calvin in Calvin
Klein adver now I've got no problem with
a more realistic representation of what
a woman's body looks like I mean mate
given the Obesity crisis
yeah actually I saw all those pictures
in New York so you're right but you just
think what is going on when we just flip
from
too thin to endangering life well both
Extremes in danger in life yeah I think
just in so many aspects of Life girls
are just being lied to and kind of
manipulated in the marketing I think a
lot of things now are saying the
opposite of what they are so editing
your face has become
empowerment self-expression it's become
a way to express how confident you are
which doesn't make any sense and then
other things like obesity being healthy
and things like you know social media
companies saying they want to connect to
you feminists saying that it's you know
liberating to sexualize yourself online
there's just so many different messages
that I think are just lying to girls
ultimately
and I mean you reading your articles I I
get the sense that you're someone who
thinks about these things quite deeply
actually so at the core of it what do
you think is going on in society
um well I think for go for the Mental
Health crisis and for young people I
think
like I said I think they're having
age-old feelings that everyone has the
insecurity
um the anxiety
and the things that are happening today
I don't think that Modern Life is Just
magnifying them I think companies are
tapping into them and exploiting them
for profit
um so I think when it comes to gen Z the
worse our mental health gets the more
companies can sell us solutions to our
Stress and Anxiety and insecurity
loneliness whatever it is
um and I think for girls today they're
stuck with this continuous conveyor belt
of you know apps and products and
procedures that are going to make us
feel better
but I think a lot of the time they're
just kind of superficial short-term
Solutions you know we're told if you
feel insecure you can get BOTOX if you
feel lonely you can get friendship
swiping out if you feel anxious you can
download this therapy app there's just
something to fix everything for us
um and I think that's why gen Z are
struggling and they're feeling so lost
is because
all of those normal emotions that you
feel are being tapped into for profit
and Freya is that the reason why we've
seen an explosion in plastic surgery
amongst young women like I see young
women in their mid-20s and they've you
know they've had worked on lip fillers
it seems that practically I sound old do
I yeah
but
I know I think that is the result of the
New Yorker did a piece on it called
Instagram face which is this idea that
there's the kind of perfect female face
which is kind of like it's basically Kim
Kardashian it's like the kind of
ethnically ambiguous big lips uh
cheekbones or um all contoured
everything
and I think girls have been exposed to
that so much that they they think that's
the kind of ideal beauty standard but
the sad thing about it is it's not girls
trying to look perfect anymore it's
girls trying to look perfect like a
computer-generated image or like the
face tuned version of Kim Kardashian and
I think girls are then trying to
replicate that filtered face in real
life which requires a lot of Botox
fillers everything like that like
um plastic surgeons are talking about
this thing Snapchat dysmorphia
which is basically that women used to
come in with pictures of celebrities
that they wanted to look like but now
they come in with pictures of themselves
with a Snapchat filter on or face tuned
and say make me look like that so I
think it's definitely yeah the result of
social media creating unrealistic Beauty
expectations that are just kind of
robotic cyborgian look that you just
can't replicate without filters
and where does feminism come into all of
this forever because you've written
about this a fair bit I take you're not
a massive fan of of it or someone else
on it yeah I'd say the
well I think it's become some of
mainstream feminism it's almost like
hypersexualizing girls kind of pandering
to the male gays doing everything that
they that women were trying to fight
against
um whether it's telling us that you know
it's empowering to yeah sexualize
yourself online or edit yourself or hook
up culture whatever it is
um I feel like it's all been placed
under the umbrella of feminism
and watered it down completely and I
think yeah girls are just being lied to
about what is
um you know beneficial for them what's
going to be good for their mental health
and uh to tell our audience what is
hookup culture because we've it's not we
would discussed it briefly with Louise
Perry and a couple of others but uh
we've never really talked about indeed
in depth what does that look like well
it's a bit difficult because
kind of two things I have there's this
rise in
casual sex
but there's also a decline in sex in
general so gen Z are having less sex
than any generation before us at the
same age we're less likely to go on
dates we're less likely to have had a
relationship
so it's not like it's kind of this crazy
hookup culture that everyone's engaging
in
but I think what is happening is
you go on a dating app and you're
basically competing in a market and
you're looking for engagement and swipes
just like you are on social media and I
think for girls to stand out in that
market and to make sure that you're
getting matches it's almost like you
feel you have to engage in casual sex or
commodify yourself objectify yourself
online
so I think when I talk about hookup
culture I mean the pressure on girls to
engage in casual sex to get a
relationship I think that's definitely
happening now but it doesn't mean that
we're having
you know way more casual sex because
we're not yeah and why not why aren't
your generation having as much sex as
previous channels um I think it's a mix
of things I think that obviously we
spend more time on screens so
we are more cautious about going out and
doing things in the real world even just
making friends so something that's like
a sexual encounter is just seems really
uncomfortable for people
um and I also think gen Z are just quite
risk-averse about relationships in
general I mean whether it's from you
know dating apps or online porn or those
things or whether it's just seeing our
parents split up you know one in three
gen Z see their parents split by the
time they're 16. so I can see how we'd
be a bit more cautious about dating and
and getting involved with that that's
really sad yeah it's really sad yeah and
the pandemic must have played a real it
must have played its own part in this
surely yeah I think all of these things
were happening before so the anxiety the
spending too long inside all of that so
Jonathan height said that teens were
already socially distanced by 2019 so
the pandemic didn't really make a big of
an impact for that but I think for girls
especially the pandemic was really bad
because
girls really depend on that face-to-face
contact whereas boys kind of they bond
through like side to side contacts stuff
like shared activities like video gaming
for example
so they spent a lot of lockdown doing
that talking to their friends gaming
whereas girls were just kind of
passively scrolling through Instagram
comparing themselves to everybody else
on their phone
and we saw this rise in school-aged
girls
um having depressive episodes girls
being taken to emergency departments for
their mental health so I think yeah
these things that were all happening
before were just exacerbated by the
pandemic and now you know we're even
further back trying to solve them
hey KK do you like trigonometry of
course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests your questions access
extra content and now the only place to
watch our Roars on catch up is on locals
our wall shows still go out at 7pm UK
time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but if you
want to watch them after this time then
you're gonna need to sign up to our
locals Ross have now become too spicy to
stay on YouTube so they're only
available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is
click on the link below this video and
for just seven dollars a month you have
access to All of This brilliant content
seven dollars a month even for someone
of my persuasion that's a bargain see
fuel on locals
and for what uh impact is Pawn making
upon your Generation
Um
I think it's a mix of things and they're
different for girls and boys so I think
a lot of it for boys is that instant
gratification thing you know they don't
need to go out and be in an
uncomfortable conversation or
try and win over a girl anymore because
they've got it on their phone
um so I think there's that but I think
for girls it creates a lot of anxiety
and paranoia about relationships you
know I don't think it's normal to know
that you're a partner or you know all of
these boys have access to you know
infinite images of women all the time I
think
that does play a part in goals anxiety
and maybe stress about relationships
attachment issues that kind of thing and
I imagine there's also a thing about
expectations like what boys expect from
their sexual partner yeah and I think
you know I think a lot of girls have
grown up as well thinking that they need
to be really sexual that they need to be
kind of like cold and detached and
that's how they're gonna find a partner
today and the kind of feminists and
celebrities are kind of enforcing that
saying you know it's empowering to be
yeah just engaging in casual sex and
um kind of being provocative online all
of these things and I think
you know for some girls I think you know
for some girls that's okay some girls
don't seem to be affected by that but
for a lot of girls that does affect
their sense of self-worth there was a
study in the Wall Street Journal which
showed that um
60 of girls at an outpatient clinic for
eating disorders depression and anxiety
had posted sexualized content on Tick
Tock
um so you know for some girls there is
evidence that it really does mess with
our you know anxiety our sense of
self-worth yeah I can really see that
and also as well
does it make the because the whole point
obviously of sex is procreation but it's
also about connection between two
partners does that mean that there's no
or there's a lack of connection there
simply because people are just trying to
recreate what they see on a screen yeah
I think romance in general has just been
kind of commodified I think that
you know you go on like a dating app and
it's like swiping through products and
you're advertising yourself like a
product you can filter through like
you're looking in like a catalog for
something
um and I think it's really kind of
romance and intimacy is just entwined
with consumer culture and it's taken out
all of the feelings from it all of the
kind of excitement and it's made it very
cold and transactional and I think I
think a lot of girls struggle with that
and I think boys as well
um you know we've grown up
on things like Instagram you know
selling ourselves online marketing
ourselves so for us it seems normal but
when you kind of zoom out and think
about it an app like Tinder is really
weird that you're advertising yourself
you're waiting for people to give you
feedback and you're tying your
self-worth to things like super likes
and how many chats you have you know
it's clearly not good for mental health
and is there a like another way I
suppose because I imagine if you're
saying well boys are like they're not
going out they're not going to approach
a girl in a coffee shop or in a pub or
whatever as they might have done in the
past then I suppose someone like you I
don't know what your relationship status
is but if you if you're looking for for
for a guy yeah to to come and approach
you but none of the guys will yeah yeah
you can you can you cannot be on Tinder
if you want but then no one's going to
approach you yeah exactly it's that
thing again you kind of forced to and I
think even things like yeah like the
Casual Sex the dating apps if you want
to meet someone it's really difficult to
not be part of that I think it's easier
for girls I think for boys uh it's
becoming less like
especially with the stuff like sexual
harassment you know there's a lot of
pressure on on guys to get it right if
they're going to go and approach a girl
but I think girls are kind of noticing
it as well there's less uh you know guys
shooting their shot I suppose I think
people are just so
um consuming things online online
content and kind of convincing
themselves they can do it that way but
they're just never gonna put it's such
an uncomfortable situation why would you
put yourself in it when you can just DM
someone on Instagram
and no we're talking about this online
culture and then for boys they they have
the incel community which they're
demonized actually if I'm being quite
honest where it's just basically men who
have decided to drop out depression we
had William costler on to talk about it
was a brilliant interview is there a
similar equivalent for girls the people
who just don't want to take part in
society and see this and think you know
what I don't want anything to do with
this I'm out yeah I think for girls it's
anxiety you know girls are driving their
eyes and anti-anxiety medication we
report having higher rates of anxiety
depression Eating Disorders so I think
for us there's this real kind of
um rising neuroticism and worrying about
things like relationships and yeah girls
aren't going on dates then they're
delaying things like their first
relationship
and I think you know we don't have as
many developmental experiences we're
spending a lot of time engaging with
online content staying inside
and so something like a relationship
just seems like this huge uncomfortable
thing and it's a mission as the kids say
and I think to them it's it's almost not
worth it you know they
for your generation that would kind of
be part of coming of age but I think
you know we we've got it all online so
yeah there's the in sales for the boys
who are um you know they're not doing it
because they don't want to approach a
girl but I think there's the girls who
are just so anxious about the
possibility of a relationship that they
they don't even want to go there I mean
I mean we're having a very sad
conversation uh if I'm going to be
honest with you because one of the
things that strikes me about this is
the the instinct to find your partner or
is so strong in human beings yeah and as
it is in all animals really so to be
able to override that to the level that
you're talking about I mean these are
powerful forces that are at play here
yeah I think well gen Z in general just
having less far less experiences so like
when your generation was young like my
parents talk about being so excited to
be independent
so excited to move out get a driver's
license you know gen Z aren't driving
we're not getting part-time jobs we're
not going on dates we're not moving out
so we're just taking much longer to
reach those traditional Milestones of
growing up
um but I think for girls that's
especially troubling because the more
you delay those things women are also
delaying marriage and motherhood in
record numbers and we know that you've
only got a short window of time to do
that and I think girls everything is
getting delayed and it also creates a
lot of different collisions so for
example girls that are now hitting
puberty much earlier so around age six
some girls and they don't know why
yes six six Jesus Christ they think it's
either obesity stress or chemicals or
something like that
um but you've got that happening so when
you have early puberty you're more at
risk of anxiety depression all of those
things anyway
and You're vulnerable to sexual
harassment predators that kind of thing
but you've got that now with the delayed
adulthood so they don't have the
developmental experiences to understand
it or process it and so I think we're in
this really dangerous position where
girls they kind of Overexposed to all
this adult content online
they're developing much earlier so
they're all the risks of that but they
don't have the life experience or the
maturity to handle it I think that is
contributing to the to the mental health
problems so
I guess the obvious question given the
sad conversation we're having so far is
what what can we do as as individuals
first of all because we can talk about
societal Solutions and they also matter
of course but at the end of the day most
people listening to this are thinking
well what do I do or what do I do for my
daughter or my son or whatever like what
what can be done about this I think well
I wouldn't say you know I have all of
the advice because yeah I'm not an
expert in it but I think realizing and
recognizing what's going on is the most
important thing so I think you know
there's a lot of like well-intentioned
parents who are letting their kids on
Tick Tock for three hours a day thinking
oh you know my daughter's not going to
view harmful content she's not going to
speak to Predators or anything like that
but I think there's a lot of things
going on that are hard to see and
measure so the effect of social media on
the development of your identity on your
sense of self-worth you can't really see
that and I think you know the one thing
parents can do is learn more about what
Tick Tock is what technologies their
daughter's using what kind of culture
they're immersed in what kind of content
they consume and learning about it if
you had a teenage child now would you
let them on social media no I wouldn't
either no I wouldn't
um and I think
but I think a lot of parents don't
realize what what it's actually doing
so I don't think you know they're to
blame that they're letting them on
social media and also it's it is their
entire social world now
um so you would be cutting them off from
you know popularity and speaking to
friends
but I think you know a lot of parents
let their kids on social media and they
do things like screen time restrictions
but they don't realize how tech savvy
kids are they can just get past it like
they can change the time on the phone
they can hack the Apple ID they can you
know if they want to view anorexia
content on Tick Tock they can spell the
hashtag slightly wrong and bypass that
so I think for parents it's about
um
becoming as tech savvy as their kids
yeah
yeah do you think this is where I am and
this is probably where I'm starting to
get more conservative as in band this
filth I do think do you think that and
we disagree on this and we've had a
discussion about it and I still stand by
it I don't understand why if you're
under the age of 16 you need to be on
social media no we disagree on it no no
as in Banning it I think you shouldn't
be allowed I think it should be by law
by law yeah well the age now is 13. I
think that's too young well tell me what
you think no I do think that's too young
I think it's something like a third of
all tick tock users or thoughts be 14 or
younger
um and so you know it's not just I think
some parents think oh it's
yeah they might see something
distressing or yeah a predator might
talk to them
but I think you know if you think how
young 13 is your brain is literally
forming it's the most vulnerable years
of your life and everything that happens
to you
kind of defines your identity As you
move forward
and so I think when you think about it
like that you know in the most
vulnerable years of their life they're
seeing content that's not just
um not just constant reels of content
but it's personalized to play on their
unique fears and insecurities all of the
time
and I think parents don't really realize
that's what's going on so you know if
you're like a 12 year old girl who say
you feel insecure about your nose you
will get content on Tick Tock for
rhinoplasty filters or editing apps or
Tick-Tock plastic surgeons so it's very
specific to the unique child and I think
that's that's unlike any kind of
advertising we've ever had before
um but I don't think parents
I don't think many parents realize how
quickly your kind of algorithm can
change to reflect things like your fears
and you don't even have to like the
content if you just hover over it you'll
get similar stuff all of the time
and do you think that's part of the
reason why we're seeing an explosion in
gender dysphoria amongst young women
yeah I mean I think you know any kind of
dysphoria you can see how
exacerbate
because you're kind of splitting
yourself into your real offline you and
then this online Persona all of the time
and you're also seeing a version of
yourself refracted back by targeted ads
and algorithms
and you know we're not just seeing the
rise in gender dysphoria it's also
things like body dysmorphia dissociative
identity disorder which is like the
multiple identities
um the realization dissociation all of
these things where girls describe
feeling detached from their body and
just separate from who they are
um and I think that is because of social
media I think
it's unnatural to have the real you and
then the you that you're selling and
Performing for the market
um and I don't I'm not saying that that
causes gender dysphoria but I think if
you already have those feelings it would
take them to the absolute extreme yeah
well a few days ago I mean it depends on
how we release episodes but we
interviewed Matt Goodman recently he
does a lot of research on uh your
generation in particular and one of the
things that I was curious to ask you
about is uh when we asked them our final
question as well as do he said like
watch out for this and Eric Kaufman has
talked about this as well there's a big
difference between girls and boys in gen
Z in terms of their political views yeah
and girls are moving way to the left
whereas boys are you know boys are boys
yeah well I I don't know are they I I I
I still when I meet young men yeah
they're still I I still I still think of
most of them as work to be honest but
um
what's going on there
um do you have any thoughts you don't
have to no yeah I think that you know
girls I think for the average kind of
gen Z person especially a girl that you
know they want to be compassionate and
tolerant and I think there's a lot of
people who think oh gen Z just want to
divide you know their their woke because
they want to tear everything down but I
think
if you take the average young girl
that's not why she's woke she's woke
because she's seeing all of this stuff
and being told that's the moral way to
be and so she's going along with it
because she wants to be a good person I
think
you know we have to
think about gen Z as you know they're
young but they're also you know they're
they want to rebel against previous
generations they want to be more
Progressive they want to do things
differently so I think that is all
normal
um and you can see why girls would go
along with it because you know we're
more likely to be agreeable you know
that ties in with political correctness
we're more risk-averse so things like
safetyism coddling you know all of those
things kind of play on our
vulnerabilities so I can see why young
girls have those opinions but I think
it's about giving them an alternative
um well I agree completely as you know
but why aren't you woke
um who are you I don't know
I think I'm just I'm a bit shy and
overthinker and I think I spent a lot of
time just observing people at Uni their
different opinions and thinking about it
and I just sort of came to the
conclusion there's sort of the woke left
and the authentic left the authentic
left you know want to uphold human
rights regulate free markets but they
want to have freedom of speech
and then there's this new left that
think that the way to do that is
policing speech and you know focusing on
this identity debates and the kind of
intricacies of language and uh I suppose
I just thought that's probably not the
way to do it but I also don't think that
I'm unique in that I do think there are
a lot of gen Z who are not woke if you
speak to
you know the people that I know I don't
know anyone with opinions like that and
I've from all over different backgrounds
not just from uni
and I think there's almost a caricature
that all of gen Z are extremely woke
we've all got these really like I don't
think I'm some big exception
um but obviously there's the vocal
minority on the Twitter yeah the other
thing that I've noticed with Gen Z is I
compare it so I
sounding old again so when I came of age
it was the 90s it was Brit pop There Was
You Know the music there was a culture
there was a fashion there was a hair you
know it was about going out Lads and
ladets drinking getting messed up taking
as much drugs and drink as you can
because that's how you had a good time
well that's what we believed at the time
I don't see a sort of a subculture or a
culture within gen Z that you when you
look back at the punks or you know rock
and roll and all of these different
things or even Emos I remember when I
started teaching in mid to late
noughties there was the Emos and the emo
bands and they had their own look but I
I never really noticed that no with
young people what's going on I think
it's again the social media algorithms
and targeted ads you know you kind of
you end up consuming so much of the same
content and being kind of
you know you're targeted via gender age
group that kind of thing so you've got
young girls all being fed the same or
similar stuff
um constantly reinforcing how you should
look you know how you could be more
desirable attractive productive happier
all of the time
and you're being served kind of
templates for that and I think people
end up the same so you have Instagram
face everyone starts looking the same
everyone starts having the same
Ambitions you know most girls something
like 57 of gen Z girls want to be
influencers now you know you see even
outfits everyone's wearing the same
outfit because
the kind of same videos are getting
pushed to all of us all of the time
and so I think there are the subcultures
but they're getting swallowed up by what
the you know the companies want to push
more off and you end up becoming defined
by you know the stuff that comes up on
your for you page and the content you
consume
um and so I think we're all becoming
kind of similar in fashion sense and
things like that and is is there a
culture where you would go out to clubs
and bars and watch bands and talk about
new bands or music or is that is that
kind of thing I love to smile on the
face this old man is talking at me about
things that have never happened well
there is but I think in general gen Z
are just doing less having less
experiences we're just less likely to go
out and do things like this and
obviously
there's loads of people who are still
doing stuff like that but I think for
the general kind of
pre-teens teenagers there's just not
really the desire to go and do those
things because you can get you know if
you want a sense of community you can
get it online if you want to find new
friends you can get them online if you
you know even things like influences
with influencers you can kind of
um you know have that sense of
connection from your bedroom and they're
using all of these kind of parasocial
marketing tactics to get you to think
that you're their friend and you end up
kind of intimately following the lives
of these strangers watching them go to
Bands then hang out with their friends
join our locals guys yeah but I think
young girls especially are doing that a
lot and I think influencers tap into
that kind of loneliness and anxiety and
then they use it in their marketing so
they say things you know they call you
your friend they show their intimate
moments in their life so you feel like
they're being real and vulnerable
but often they're just trying to sell
you something or get engagement so it's
quite sad really yeah and it's it's not
a real connection no well online
communities I mean look you know people
make friends online I don't want to
denigrate that or people meeting their
Partners online
but it it's not like having a real group
of friends you know it's not like having
a family it's not like meeting people
it's not
it's completely synthetic yeah that you
get sort of a quick hit of that sense of
connection and you get like
you know someone replies to a comment
and they relate to you and they are
going through the same thing or yeah if
you if you feel like you're struggling
with your mental health you can go
online and there's a community for that
exact mental health problem that exact
issue you're going through you know it's
very attractive for lonely kind of
awkward girls to want to you know find
their connection that way
um so I can see why people do it but I
think that kind of instant hit wears off
and and in the end it is just a
superficial community and often those
communities will drop you as soon as you
don't meet you know what they're talking
about if it's like
um a social justice Community for
example if you change your mind you're
no longer going to be accepted
um so I think young people likewise if
you're an insult and you're like oh you
know what I've actually decided I like
girls yeah exactly so I think part of
you know helping gen Z is mental health
also the woke staff is just getting them
to engage with people and have more
experiences because I think the more you
do that something like the woke world
view just falls apart because you
realize that people from all different
backgrounds we've all got different
traumas we've all been through similar
things
and the kind of idea that you know we're
all in distinct identity groups it just
doesn't work when you go out and
actually engage with the world so I
think a lot of gen Z's problems would be
solved through more experiences and one
thing you alluded to earlier which is
something that we've talked to death on
the show but I still think and he's
talking about it's a breakdown of the
family and the impact that has yeah and
that just seems to be accelerating and
accelerating Etc yeah
um yeah well I wrote an article about
um the glamorizing of divorce like
I've seen everywhere like the guardian
was talking about the joy of divorce
parties uh yeah the like Vogue was
talking about this Valentine's Day let's
hear it for divorce the New York Times
called divorce a radical Act of
self-love so I'm seeing all of this I
was also researching gen Z's Mental
Health crisis and reading through all of
these reports and all of the reports
would talk about things like the economy
the climate crisis being reasons for Gen
Z's anxiety which just doesn't make
sense to me I don't think a 13 year old
cares more about the climate or the
economy than if their parents are
talking I think it's a lot of it is
closer to home
um and I think there's this denial going
on about it because you know we've got
the most mentally ill generation on
record and family breakdown is just
barely mentioned even though we know
that having divorced parents leads to
you're more vulnerable to anxiety
depression Eating Disorders substance
abuse there was even a study that showed
that it has parental divorce has more of
a negative impact on educational
attainment than parental death so we
know that it has a huge impact and yeah
it isn't factored into the Mental Health
crisis and why sorry Francis I just want
to finish at this point
um why do you think that is forever
because I know that like in our day it
was you can't talk about the breakdown
of the family because you're demonizing
hard-working single moms that's the
argument right is that still the
argument or is there a different or is
it or is being like is every form of
family quote unquote they're all equally
valid now is is yeah I think it's a mix
of things I think
is just this idea in Modern Life that
everything should be fun and easy
all the time and any kind of
responsibility is restrictive and
inconvenient and so I think a lot of
parents kind of lived by that they kind
of were conditioned by Society to think
you know the ultimate freedom is your
own happiness I think for some for some
marriages obviously there's reasons for
divorce but I think that was also
happening
um and I think now we're seeing the
consequences of that and I think a lot
of parents are still maybe in denial
about
um the impact that it's had because it
was something like they asked Children
of Divorce how it affected them and
parents brought our five parents said
that their children were fine with it
whereas literally 75 of the children had
had things like anxiety depression
Eating Disorders substance abuse it's a
hard thing to admit of course especially
if you've if you felt that the divorce
was you know important or necessary or
it was genuinely you know people don't
always can't always keep it up but it's
just we've seen over the last 60 70
years that rate is skyrocketed in every
Western Society I think it's too close
to home for people because if you're
talking about it everyone knows someone
who's gone through a divorce or their
parents have or so it's really hard to
talk about and it's much easier to look
at things like the financial crash or
the climate whereas I think for young
people their world is their friends and
family it's who's close to them and I
think something like divorce makes much
more sense to me why you would feel
anxious than something far away like the
climate crisis
and what is what is your generation's
attitude to Motherhood do you do the
girls still want to get married do they
still believe in that married you know
having two kids a family or are they
kind of more seeking a careers and all
of that path yeah well I think it's uh
half of women are now childless by their
30th birthday uh in England and Wales
um and there's loads of reasons for that
obviously you know decline of religion
feminism
um but I think there's been an attitude
shift in gen Z through my experiences I
don't know any women in their early 20s
who are excited about motherhood who
talk about it who
have it in their Vision I think we're
either terrified of it or we don't want
to or we're putting off as long as why
are you terrified of this
uh I don't think I am no no I'm sorry
you said we are yeah and I said you like
I think what's the source of that it's
that kind of message again from society
that you should only pursue things that
make you comfortable and happy and I
think we've kind of emphasized the
personal discomfort of it you know
everything you'll sacrifice
you know we've grown up in societies
with more comfort and convenience than
ever before so it makes sense that we
would be more risk-averse about anything
uncomfortable
um like if you go on Child free Tick
Tock it has like 780 million views and
it's
a lot mostly girls pretty much all girls
talking viscerally against motherhood uh
you know there's one that does a free
birth control Series where she just
shows you like the most horrifying
aspects of motherhood whether it's
losing sleep or your child being sick on
you all of these things
and all of the comments are just like
they don't even understand why you would
ever do that because they just think oh
it's all about personal discomfort
and to them it seems puzzling why you
would want to have children because it
just gets in the way of that so much but
I think it's kind of sad because I think
a lot of gen Z will miss out or delay
something meaningful
for their own personal discomfort so
they can live their best life
um and I think it might backfire do you
think it's part of the reason is a whole
generation which is essentially had
their brains hacked to believe that
instant gratification is the best form
of gratification
and children are not instantly
gratifying a lot of the time yeah yeah I
think yeah any of these meaningful
things that where you have to your
gratification is delayed you have to
compromise and sacrifice
I think as a whole we find those things
uh much more daunting because we've had
comfort and convenience at our
fingertips you know anything we want we
can kind of have much quicker than your
Generations did you know you'd have to
if you wanted to speak to a girl you'd
have to get the courage to do it
um if you wanted to get a job you'd have
to get the courage to go in and ask
about it you know all of these things
have been made much more convenient
which is good but then I think we've
developed this irrational fear of
things like discomfort and sacrifice and
I think that's why part of why we're
seeing
decline in motherhood marriage because
those things do come with with
compromise and discomfort and
we've seen the rise of Andrew Toad and
we I've talked to people with a lot of
people and a lot of them people have
been my age or older about it and they
talk about it why do you think he's
become such a huge figure to young men
and boys in particular and what impact
is that having amongst women of your
generation I think for boys they're
hearing the same messages over and over
again which is obviously the
kind of demonizing masculinity saying
you need to become more sensitive you
need to be almost more like women in the
way that you think about things and
approach things and I think
you know men tend to just process their
emotions differently and think about
things differently you know it doesn't
make us make them wrong but I think now
we're almost
telling men that all of the ways they do
it are toxic or um too blunt or so
they're trying to kind of become more
feminine
um and so I think someone like Andrew
Tate comes along and he has a masculine
approach to it quite heavy-handed and a
bit blunt but I think for men that's
appealing because it's the same with
girls you know they're being lied to
quite often and kind of convinced that
there's something wrong with them
and then you have someone come along and
say oh well if you have these masculine
traits then it's a good thing you can be
strong you can do this whatever
um so I can see why that's appealing and
I think
yeah I think yeah yeah no well it makes
sense and I said it at the time what I
find very puzzling although it's not
puzzling I think the answer is quite
obvious it's like whenever anyone comes
along who uh Taps into that frustration
that young men feel about like this is
how I am but I'm being told that the way
that I am is wrong right whether it's a
Jordan Peterson or an Andrew Tate who
who I have my reservations about no one
ever goes why is that no one ever goes
like why why am I doing this yeah what
are they lacking exactly they're filling
a vacuum yeah I don't know I think
yeah it's just we hear the same messages
over and over again and when someone has
something different to say it's really
appealing
um and there's there's probably stuff
within what he's saying that is useful
that boys should be listening to but we
kind of need to
listen as well and figure out what that
is I think Andrew Tate is a very good
example of what happens when there are
not enough healthy Role Models yeah so
someone who is as out there as he is
will come along and Hoover up their
attention because no one else is
speaking to that audience and they give
people
lines to follow like he'll say this is
what you need to do to be a man and then
they've kind of got markers to check off
whereas you know we're living in these
consumer cultures without you know the
decline of religion and things like that
we don't have those set guidelines of
how to come of age what gives us purpose
what we should be following so when
someone comes along and says oh this is
how you live a happier life things like
that then people are going to listen and
as well when you think about the fact
that the divorce rate is what it is a
lot of boys are growing up there's no
male figure in the household they go to
school most of their teachers are women
they're surrounded by women education
has become more and more feminized so
traditional male behavioral types like
boisterousness you know but wanting to
be physically active uh actively looked
down upon then someone comes in to give
what in their eyes is a positive vision
of masculinity why wouldn't they follow
it yeah and I wrote a piece about um how
the kind of social justice activism the
culture today is very feminine in nature
so things like cancer culture and women
are more likely to use indirect methods
of aggression like reputation
destruction social exclusion you know
we're more likely to be risk-averse so
safetyism is kind of parallels you know
typical female Behavior
and I think a lot of this stuff that's
happening in culture is feminine in
nature
and some boys and men don't feel like
they fit into that they don't that's not
how
um they would have Society be and you
know it's not because they're wrong
um and I think yeah so someone masculine
comes along it's very attractive to them
because it probably aligns more with
their traits than the culture now and
the other thing that I find worrying is
so he's imprisoned nobody knows if he's
guilty or innocent
and but people think right okay that's
it the problem is dealt with we've got
rid of him and I'm there thinking well
no the problem isn't dealt with because
then somebody else is going to come
along and tap into it yeah maybe worse
yeah exactly yeah it's true I think we
yeah like you said there's a vacuum
there that some someone they're feeling
a demand for something
um so we need to figure out what what
that demand is for and and try and
figure out what it is within that
kind of ultra masculine front that
someone like Angie Tate has what is it
that they find attractive about that
like because there is value in it surely
there is if so many people are
interested in it well there's definitely
value in it in the sense that he you
know if you're telling people to take
response men men particularly to take
responsibility to pursue their dreams
these these are things that a lot of men
of your generation never heard in their
lives they've never been encouraged
um but then you know as I said I think
someone who says this you should only
see your children once a year or
whatever it's probably gone in the wrong
direction there so that's why I say
healthy role models and uh you know I
think that's why Jordan Peterson
actually became as big as he became
because he was like take responsibility
here's some rules you know yeah um and I
I think I think that it's important for
people like that to be coming through
yeah and giving positive uh visions of
masculinity and for society to stop
demonizing yeah and I think that's what
men respond they've responded to the
kind of pick yourself up and sort
yourself out girls don't really respond
to that in the same way you know we we
need a different approach
um and I think
boys don't really have that in society
it's all about like you're doing fine
you're you know relaxed de-stress take
on less challenges whereas a lot of boys
mental health problems might come from
the fact that they're not being pushed
maybe they want to be pushed they want
to take on more challenges
um so I think when someone comes along
using that male approach is really
appealing to them do you think that on
the flip side of it though we also
feminine we also demonize traditional
femininity as well to some extent I mean
um my wife before she before she she had
her son she was always working yeah and
she's now with our son and not working
nearly as much and you start to see that
actually it's probably quite hard being
just like a mum yeah whereas in the I
mean my mum was uh a housewife or her
all her life she has actually a very
interesting business now but there was
never really as much of an issue she she
was not demonized for doing that it may
be also whether the culture that I come
from as well you know in Russian culture
was a bit different but I I think if you
were to say to your mates and I'm just
hypothesizing but I'm guessing you know
what I just I just want to stay at home
with the kids you probably have quite a
hard time yeah they'd find that
oppressive again restrictive like what
if you chose it would that still be
oppressive yeah I think they would think
I've chosen it because I've been
convinced conditioned to think by your
husband or whatever yeah right uh it's
interesting because you've got the
people kind of demonizing masculinity
but then kind of encouraging girls to be
more and more masculine like the
becoming cold and detached in
relationships so that you can you know
find a partner that way through casual
sex then you won't get hurt things like
that
um even in yeah working we're more
encouraged to be masculine independent
um so you know it's either one or the
other even masculine traits are good
things or they're not and it seems to be
yeah both traditional femininity and
masculinity are getting demonized in
different ways all right well before we
wrap up then what do we do about all
this
um well I don't know I think for like I
said for a lot of these issues gen Z
needs to get out more and have more
experiences because I think the more
time on your screen it's worse for your
mental health you know you've got that
constant social comparison the targeted
ads and algorithms and you're not
experiencing life and I think that plays
into the woke stuff as well you're just
saying in the same online communities
getting served the same content
um and I don't think that's good for
mental health I don't think it's good
for your development in general so I
think yeah that's the one thing that
young people can do
um yeah
so it's been an absolute pleasure
we always finish with the the final
question which is always what's one
thing we're not talking about as a
society that we really should be I think
it's girls mental health I think we are
talking about it a lot but we need to be
talking about it with more compassion
you know these aren't problems that are
just nothing new I think that um you
know this crisis is the product of a
lifetime of conditioning I think that
girls we're the first generation of
girls to be made to feel insecure
anxious unwell
um all the time online to maximize
profit and boost engagement and I think
you know people need to realize how
girls are being manipulated and misled
and the corporations that are cashing in
on it and I think for girls it's about
you know afrogenzi in general not
punishing themselves for feeling anxious
and depressed and all of these things
and
rather than feeling anxious about what's
wrong with them and feeling angry that
they're growing up in a world like this
and that yeah corporations are
capitalizing on it and also taking
action I would I would suggest I mean
being angry for the sake of it isn't
going to change anything yeah being
angry and empowered to make a change in
their own lives for their own mental
health yeah well said Freya I really
recommend everybody read your articles I
hope you keep writing on your sub stack
which I've been really enjoying and I
look forward to your book thank you it's
exciting times we're going to ask you a
couple of questions uh that aren't from
our locals that only they will get to
see but for now thank you so much and
thank you guys for watching and
listening we'll see you another
brilliant episode like this one or raw
show all of them go out at 7pm UK time
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast so you won't need
to look at your screens take care and
see you soon get off the phone and go
and for a walk or something yeah but
make sure to listen to us yeah while
you're walking
is the increase in teenage girls using
mental health services evidence that we
need more Mental Health Services or is
that evidence that such services are
actually making things worse
foreign
[Music]